hello everybody and thank you for
joining us on the corridor digital
podcast
um we have a very special guest today uh
if you didn't see in the title uh mark
the intern has joined us and uh
apparently he's got a youtube channel so
mark thanks for being here man hey
thanks so much uh just an honor and a
privilege to move up from it i get as a
promotion right yes okay cool
yeah you now get talent credit wow
does that get paid i wasn't paid before
no not yet
credit is the payment
health insurance uh benefits dental
dream
okay
in due time right now we'll give you
college credits okay it's cool you're
still in college right technically i
have not graduated so uh
wait are you another are you another uh
creator who didn't graduate from college
you got that right i dropped out
two semesters away from graduating yes
okay so who else is in that boat nico
aren't you in that boat no i got my
degree i got okay
i got no you guys agree okay
well brandon's in that boat freddy's in
that boat ren are you in that boat no i
got my degree um no one cares though
yeah yeah well yeah that's true well
it's because like i realized i wanted to
do youtube videos about a month and a
half before i graduated and at that
point i'm like well i might as well just
graduate i'm like so close i i was doing
youtube for a while while i was still in
school um but only carried on for about
maybe a semester or two before i was
like uh maybe i should go whole hog into
this thing and look at me now i'm an
intern at a corridor
did you um like have big plans at
college or was it just kind of like well
everybody's going so i'll go because
that's i think how most people end up
going yeah pretty much you know just the
general idea of like oh this is the
right thing to do after high school oh
yeah engineering it's a good solid job
and
i hated every second of it
you know jake this college talk it's
really interesting but we might want to
just pause for a second since like we
just slipped right into it we should be
just talking a little bit about why
mark's joined us why he's here all right
fine do the do the formalities nico
let's go
so all you mark nurse is actually
interning here i guess uh
legitimately you are here to kind of
just experience and learn a little bit
yeah
it's like auditing a class i think yeah
but i'm i'm trying to help out wherever
i can i literally walked into the first
meeting and i was like yeah i'll give
people coffee i just like the idea of uh
soaking in knowledge because there's a
lot of for all the knowledge for all the
smash games and all the goofing around
there is a lot of knowledge that floats
around in the air like the ether is
soaked with knowledge it's a thick ether
here at corridor
yeah i think auditing a class is
probably a better uh
uh
preferred preferred
categorization of this um
you know i actually i had jerry
o'connell audit a class when i was in
law school
yeah you know the actor he's in like uh
i don't know he's in he's in um
what's that really old stand by me that
really old kids movie or it's not a kids
movie
yeah not as a child as a man
yeah and uh and then he was in my law
school class he told everyone he was
going to law school he's very serious
about it and he's like no i just want to
go and then of course he drops out after
the first year and then he goes and does
a show about being a lawyer oh
interesting so it was like well why'd
you lie to us jerry
i mean aren't actors technically
professional liars
i i guess so or are they
saying the most truthful things
they're like professional liars who
don't intend to defraud anybody yeah
anyways well we you're not our first
uh dang it what did you literally just
call it auditing you're not our first
auditor
no the irs wasn't either
[Laughter]
wes was technically uh another auditor
as well
auditors i'm calling it
all right auditors sure uh yeah wes kind
of approached us the same way it's
really cool getting like
new creative energies into the studio
because it gives like
when i
share like
a bit of like knowledge or teaching with
somebody it helps me learn it and so
it's always nice to have the excuse to
like have somebody be like hey can you
show me how this is done and it's like
yes because then i can show myself how
it's done and therefore lock it in into
mine it's like a goal you need a certain
amount of knowledge to be able to pass
it on so you're like oh god i better
have that much knowledge
i had this idea to do
like an internship here for a long time
actually i just didn't know when i would
have the time for it um but when i
flowed the idea to you you were like
yeah you know that's kind of how it's
been before and i never thought of it
that way because i remember when wes was
here and like the videos that he was in
and i just thought like he was just
someone you hired on for a bit and
passed on through i didn't know that
that was the situation but it's cool
like it's extremely cool to be uh
welcoming like this you know i know
there's probably a lot of
not comparing quarter to like content
houses or white houses or things like
that but there's a lot of like youtube
conglomerates out there not that this is
a conglomerate anyway it's okay is there
any good books
corporation all of the words that are
associated with combined youtube
channels together have such a negative
connotation
it is hard
yeah but this crew we're a
multi-corridor network
don't you dare it's it's it's really
nice and i've always admired the stuff
that you guys do i think people know for
a fact or who have like watched the
video that i was on or watched any of my
videos where i talked about is like you
guys are a great inspiration to a lot of
other youtubers and a lot of people that
want to be youtubers or not even
youtubers just like content creation in
general filmmaking tv shows writing i i
think there's a lot of people that take
a lot of inspiration from what you guys
do here oh yeah cool that's great
and now the badge you specifically so
i mean after today that'd be fair we did
the most intense render challenge today
it was super intense yeah that took a
while it was fun i had a lot of fun i
had a blast i had a blast i don't know
how they're gonna edit that one down
because like was that five hours of
footage that we got that wasn't five it
was like three
four
you guys what was the challenge
uh the challenge that we essentially did
was
i was trying to create a render but i
couldn't touch the computer or keyboard
or mouse at all
and so i was the vessel with which he
poured his knowledge into
hazardly splashing
place on the table but uh yeah no it was
a very fun idea and it also was an
opportunity for me to learn which i
think is really cool that you uh had a
video where literally i had to touch a
program that i have never touched before
you have you ever mucked around in 3d
program before i mean in engineering
school like autocad i think is what i
work with and then solid works he
reminded me of gotcha
am i remiss
[Laughter]
but yeah no honestly it it kind of
impressed me because like we went in
with a plan of what to sort of make and
you were being uh you you were making
trouble
and that was something that i should
have anticipated but somehow didn't and
uh so that was that was very fun because
i have to remind myself it's just it's
for the video i know you're just doing
it but um
at the same time you are also actually
retaining everything that i was telling
you to do to a degree that legitimately
impressed me oh thank you uh like i was
kind of blown away because when we came
back from one break i think and then you
you just started rattling off all the
things that you had done up until that
point but like
with a high degree of detail about
specifically all the shortcuts i told
you all the different options i told you
to go through and change and you rattled
all them off that's a thank you i am
incredible and uh everything
but no like that's just how my memory
works is like if i did something i'm a
very much
doing memory kind of person not good
with words apparently but you know i'm a
do memory
yes you did i don't think that has to do
with memory i think that's something
uh but it's like if i do something i can
remember something that's the best way i
learned and that's how i wanted to learn
that's why i wanted to come here just
like be in this environment literally
tell me what to do i will do it i will
try it i will do the best i can and if i
can't do it then you know i didn't try
hard enough when i'm when i'm like going
out to try something when i want to try
something new or i'm trying to put
something together just you know
going for something like
i usually picture a moment in my mind
that like represents oh this is like an
ideal moment from that like we all went
and saw rr in the theater this past
weekend yeah i had this ideal moment of
us literally hands in the air cheering
at a very specific point in the movie
which i once spoke here and that moment
happened so i felt like i achieved my
dream
so when you're thinking about coming
over here do you have one of those
moments in your mind
um when i lead the uprising against all
the leadership of corridor and like i
rally all of the people working here and
we overthrow
[Laughter]
it's like
the corridor coups
i don't have a specific moment like that
i just really want to walk away from
this with everybody in tears from how
much they'll miss me uh no i don't even
know how to be serious with it it's just
like i just want to have fun i want to
have a good time i want to work hard i
want to prove to you guys that i'm here
not just to goof around or mooch off
your snacks
which you have
great snacks
but shout out to jordan for that yeah i
just i just hope to you know leave an
impression here walk away with some
knowledge and maybe
it'd be cool if i come back every once
in a while yeah man i mean that's
western okay can we pause for a second
on this idea and talk about corridor
coup for a moment and maybe it can be
like a suck a second channel
and it's mark trying to overthrow
corridor and
we don't know what's happening but he's
constantly trying to
attack what if i've already started it
what if i've already registered the
domain what if i've already i hope
i hope you have yeah he's got a dot cord
or coup shirt on
but we have to actually not register the
domain now that we've talked about it in
this podcast i know we have to do it
before we release this podcast yeah like
when like tv shows like say something
they have to actually have the domain or
something like that no i'm not saying
they have to i'm just saying we should
someone else will grab it if you don't
exactly yeah we'll grab that now that
we've talked about it we've made it a
thing
yeah we also
have a car channel called chord or coupe
wow the e on the end keep it going
[Laughter]
you know i have probably enjoyed in the
past when we've done like
the office style like story lines in
like our behind the scenes videos where
it's like we invent a little bit of
extra lore like the peter clone saga
yeah yeah yeah i briefly thought about
whether or not we should try to bring
that back
i do that all the time in my videos like
i do gaming videos mostly but even like
and i do like higher production stuff
but even my normal videos i always love
weaving a through thread like i was
telling someone else earlier today about
this kind of like side uh character in
my videos which is my editor lixie and
he animates himself into the videos a
lot but he has an evil version of him
called lunky
because he was on vacation and i hand
drew him and he's evil and it's there's
this like whole plot of him trying to
fight the evil version of himself he's
killed him before he's back from the
dead he's monstrous it's just like
little flavor bits like that weaving
through videos is my favorite thing it's
an eternal tapestry of of a story and
things can fall away and die but i i did
love that when you know peter getting
shot all the time with like with the
arrow and then just like drag him away
and then a new peter comes in like it's
really fun like the surreal elements of
uh youtube like it lends itself to it
because all of it is like it's a version
of reality that you package and edit
down for consumption and entertainment
there is like that real side that i do
appreciate but there's always like this
whimsical side that you can play with
people's expectations and it's fun like
it's just fun to do so i recommend you
do but nothing messes with people more
than doing a little bit of visual
effects on a behind-the-scenes moment
yes they're like whoa yeah that's real
[Laughter]
yeah because you're not expecting it in
that context
you know you think it's like a reality
context and then something weird happens
and
you're shocked by it yeah it just blows
people away more because they were they
were not guarded for it they didn't
expect it to happen so he's just like oh
my god didn't we do that in the alien on
your head video yeah
yeah because that was back when i was
actually running the crew channel back
when it was called sam and nico and i
was making the behind the scenes for
there's an alien on your head and this
is the predecessor to peter getting shot
with the arrow
where uh it was you and clint
were having this debate about getting
shot uh was was it you shooting clint or
was it clint she's shooting me clint's
like i can do it i can shoot you i'm
like i don't know
i don't think we should do this
it was like i can do this i won't miss
yeah i'll be like five feet away and i
was like
no
it built up to this moment where he
eventually actually does shoot you
except he doesn't actually
shoot you because
uh the arrow was already in your chest
and just for like that one second i
painted out the arrow and tracked in an
arrow on on the the bow and had him
shoot and we just never acknowledged it
it was just like in the lore of that
video he actually did shoot you and it
pierced your chest and into your
skin and everything and
you fall down into the thing we're like
okay
you have level three body armor on and
somehow the the arrow pierced through it
yeah the ceramic plates i love it
because it's like the light side of vfx
and the dark side of vfx you know using
it for evil like with when they stole
your voice
i really unironically love that video
legality aside
that was very funny when you said
god when you were like you know in texas
they say come and take it and say i was
like well i came and did it
for about five minutes straight it was
so funny
i was i knew something was up but i
didn't quite know what and we talked
about this on a different podcast after
that video but
like you know i kind of knew something
was happening because
of all the circumstances that were going
on and then i didn't know exactly what
until that call but yeah that was that
was great i
i applaud everybody who was involved in
that because it got they got me
did robo jake do an ad read in that
video i can't remember if that was yes
uh not the whole thing but there was a
couple lines that dean snuck in there i
i feel like i actually not that i not
that i skipped through the ad reads i
would never do that never recommend let
anybody do that but i do remember
distinctly watching the entirety of that
i don't remember what it was about
that's
also i rarely watch our ad reads
obviously but like that was one that i
watched all the way through also
obviously
obviously oh i've already seen them
in their individual forms you're right
you're right yeah
yeah
yeah no i um
i'm glad people watch the ad reads i'll
just say that like
we try hard on them
and uh so i'm glad i'm glad people enjoy
them
i love goofing with ad reads i love
making them funny it's something that
companies don't understand is you came
to us who was i talking to this about
you came to us
uh me actually yeah i was talking to you
i was like yeah these companies come to
you and they're like you we love how you
interact with your audience and the
videos make can you do something
completely different than that and so
like uh for the podcast that i have with
uh my buddies bob and wade we literally
have a a
stipulation that we will not do an ad in
list if you have any reviews we will not
do an ads you have to trust us and that
way we can i love that we run with ads
there's no reviews we just like blasted
out whatever chaos and and the funny
thing is
we are one of the very few
uh podcasts where people will go back
and listen to our ads specifically
because we make them funny we make them
engaging and fun and so the bits that
we're doing cause people to want to
listen to it and it's like yes exactly
don't you want people to want to list
your ad read we get the url at the end
of the ad in there like we get all your
talking points in there but we just make
up fun improvements while you're here i
really want to try that with you
yeah
let's do it let yeah let's do an ad read
on a crew video and you and i will do it
together and and we'll just
run the thing and we'll say okay
guys this ad read had no
uh notes from client ready all right go
i would love to go ham like the interns
ad for
i would be honored to make one of those
happen
i would watch that ad yeah so long as
you just like let me go ham with it i
would i would be so tickled but like i i
feel like this is the context behind
this is probably not something that most
people really like understand they know
that we do ads and stuff for companies
but like they probably don't fully
realize that we have to have like that
ad segment prepared like way in advance
so that we could send it to the client
and then they can review it and go
through their own corporate ladders to
get it reviewed sometimes that could
take a couple days and then they'll come
back with notes like oh we didn't like
that one thing you said here and like
like whatever and then it's like
we gotta address these notes so you go
back and you make those changes and
sometimes it can be a big deal sometimes
it can be a problem
and some yeah and so it's not too often
these days not too often not too often
these days like the last year so it's
not been too big of a thing because like
we've done enough we got enough of like
a pipeline and a workflow and like a
rhythm more than anything and christians
and also christian's an amazing producer
absolutely
but i don't know i i uh
it's just one of those things that it's
like it's always kind of like
i want to do it my way exactly yeah and
if you do it your way will seem uh more
natural more natural everything that
with ads the main reason people don't
watch them i don't think is because it
seems disingenuous half the time even if
it is even if you actually do like the
product that you're you're you're
selling or promoting like it doesn't
matter to people because they're not
like oh man you sell out you've changed
i like old corridor
i think that's why i i kind of like
drove the character that is me doing the
ad reads to like uh out of touch almost
disingenuous person not like
not like you know
intentionally disingenuous but just like
so out of it doesn't quite know what's
happening
because it's it's more of a natural fit
to just like rattle off anything when
you're playing a character who could say
anything as it is i do actually
unironically like the way you do ads i i
think that it's it's one of the few
people that do adding grace especially
regular app integrations with with
content that they make where it is
engaging or the effort there to make it
engaging is clear and apparent so i do
appreciate the work that you put into it
because it is it is rarer these days
most most times especially like you here
on other pockets they're just like this
is sponsored by whatever bed company
we're responsible i love this bed i have
this bed they don't have that
you know this is like except for this
one bed company that sponsored us where
they sent a bed to my house and i'm like
i love it thank you but also where am i
going to put this bed
now you can say you have the bed okay
even if it's in your garage
dog bed
oh absolutely 100 except it's a queen
size bed
so jake you're you're usually the one
who does most of our ad reads
occasionally uh we will do some of these
ads you know i often do a lot of the
audible ones but that's because i
legitimately use audible and love it so
much
uh but it's now become a bit of a thing
where you're like people are saying like
oh you just do the ads how does that
make you feel about like being the ad
guy
i mean i've said this before i i think
just any time you get a chance to be in
one of the videos it's it's kind of you
know not something to be taken for
granted so i just try to appreciate it
and have fun with it um
and you know like i i kind of
molded my
creative brain
through the trial and error
and the tests of when brands would come
to us and say hey we have this idea
what would you guys do with it
so what the normal process especially
back uh when we were doing this for
corridor videos when there was like
fully dedicated corridor videos what i
would do is i would go okay
i'll come up with some ideas and then
i'd pitch them to sam and nico
and then we'd talk about him make some
revisions and then we'd pitch him back
and if those got accepted then i would
end up kind of show running usually
those productions into
the shoot
and so everything from like handling
you know what they wanted and what was
important to them versus what was
important to sam and nico i i kind of
lived in that creative space to begin
with so i got very comfortable in that
space
um just
by nature of what i was doing for
corridor anyway
um
so i i don't know i think it's kind of
funny when people like say what does
that guy even do
you know i think it means that we've
succeeded
yeah oh i i have a question for you mark
oh yeah
so you've been a fan of corridor for a
long time yes it's very evident
what do you miss from old corridor oh
man that's a good question oh
interesting um the hard-hitting
questions
god
everything for instance the name
corridor digital
i forget who i was talking about with
that it was like yesterday like uh
someone was was you i forget someone was
saying like they're talking about like
oh yeah uh corridor digital and they're
like confused like huh
you mean corridor crew
now nothing uh nothing really stands out
in terms of like topical things like
that when names logos it's whatever it's
the people right and one of the
beautiful things that corridor has is um
for for the most part and honestly even
even better about it is like the main
people that were there in the beginning
are still there there's so many youtube
channels that exist especially group
channels uh or collaborative channels
that exist um and then they go past the
point where they've lived out their life
and then the people go their separate
ways and the original people are not
there i mean i could list off some names
but i don't want to like put any people
like on blast or anything it's it's not
a thing it's just life it happens um and
with corridor like
it still feels even with an office full
of people it still feels true to not
only the message and like what was
trying to be made
so many years ago but
also just like the people are still
there and you've had a chance to see
them grow um see them grow older these
will grow wiser see them grow
like maybe a couple gray hairs here and
there
i have actually started noticing gray
hairs on me it's wild yeah i'm sorry to
notice quite a few coming in now um but
you know growing up with that
looking back and saying that i miss
something no i don't because there's so
much more of the same thing that i loved
back when i started than there is now
there's just more of it there's more of
the people that i enjoyed watching
there's more of the like the high
production videos maybe like it's a bit
more sporadic here and there but i
noticed the effort isn't like reduced
overall there's a lot more effort put
into corridor crew and so
honestly i don't miss anything about it
uh now i'm so grateful because i get a
chance to interact with you guys and
like hang out with you guys so i don't
know maybe i'm maybe i'm biased because
of that but to be perfectly honest
people look at my content and they're
like i miss the old markiplier and i'm
like what about it
what about it do you miss i missed your
red hair man yeah
hair that wasn't even the early
markiplier that was like mid markiplier
you know
people miss i've been on youtube long
enough that people miss multiple
different phases of me like this is the
best and i'm like hey at least yeah we
can relate to that 100 as well
especially when we started like doing
the vlogs they're like i miss when you
guys just did behind the scenes for your
actual stuff and then like we did that
for a couple years and then we started
shifting to more story based stuff like
i missed the every other day uploads and
it's like you go through phases of new
audience members who miss that certain
uh
phase when they became a fan yeah yeah
exactly um but it's like you just do
this long enough they're like i don't
know what to tell you hey did people
know about corridor uh corridor is it
corridor digital.com yeah
because i'm that that shirt is throwing
me off quarterdoodle.com where they can
see crew cuts which just entered season
two and is even better than ever and
where they can get crew producer points
so that they can vote towards their
favorite new shows that are gonna come
out yeah do they not know about this
wonderful website do they
do that do you guys know about this i
hope they know about it well they
probably know about it now
i love crew cuts i i i haven't caught up
with them as much as i should just
because i've been a little busier but
like it's those happens so well made
they're so well made they got the same
feel as the ones from uh sam and nico
you know or like earlier times they're
still there if anything better honestly
just because the uh ability for people
to like actually put quality they're way
better
they're
i mean we were making very different
things
like i don't think it's quite comparable
no i don't want to compare it i'm just
saying people naturally will but like
the storytelling on the
crew cuts vlog and on the crew channel
now is just
it's it's so much more refined if you go
back and watch a video from like
you know
2012 2013 2014 like those videos are
fine but you can just see the the the
quality and the artistic evolution
through it which is fun to me i think
that's really actually really cool
mark when did you start youtube mr me
started youtube yeah uh it would have
been um
uh
march of 2012. i just saw everybody in
my 10-year actually i launched space on
the 10-year was april 4th was when i
uploaded my first video but i first
started trying to make a video
towards mid-march and failed
spectacularly so just about 10 years
yeah that's crazy it's it's weird to
think that
this job that we're doing is like old
news now that's like yeah
you know we got into it's like oh the
new media you guys are new media you're
on the frontier yeah youtube youtube's
like the oldest video platform that
people use so i was i was in uh i was in
a lift on the way to the airport uh the
other day from the studio and i i ended
up talking to the driver the whole way
and uh
he was
i don't i asked him how old he he was
but he wouldn't give me an answer but he
was younger he was like maybe mid-20s uh
younger than us and uh
he was saying that youtube to him is
like tv
because it's it's like the hardest
social media platform to
to do
now harder so that's just
interesting
yeah like the hardest one to
you know i guess
make a living at is i guess is what he
was saying i don't know if that's true
you know i think there's a lot of people
who
um so we have a pretty difficult time on
instagram and tick tock and all the
others but
i sometimes forget that people make a
living on other social medias and they
look at it like that i i've never looked
at it as a way to do
uh any sort of brand deal or making
money there's been some brand deals that
require a tweet or something like that
but i forget sometimes that people just
look at social media in terms of like
breaking into it making a living and i
forget it's not just a communication
platform yeah sorry was i interrupting
uh no no i just thought it was an
interesting tidbit because like you guys
were saying when we first started it was
kind of
the the you know
it was the
the new home
yeah yeah it was the new hotness but to
the tv and movie people we were kind of
in this scrubby little corner
you know and
we we were just a bunch of miscreants
doing whatever we were doing over there
and what do you mean you could make
money on youtube it's like yeah yeah
launching a new youtube channel now is a
little bit like trying to launch a new
tv channel you know 15 years ago 20
years ago where it's like chandler show
channel okay where it's like i'm gonna
drop a new cable channel and try to get
people to come watch it it's like man
you really have to like get to hit that
hard back in the day to make that work
and
now it's like the same thing i think
with youtube i mean to me it's like if
you're trying to
start a new channel or a new show
like youtube oriented you really have to
have
something new
and i feel like that's super difficult
now because so many people like the
entire world's population has swept
through this and like so everything's
almost been highlighted or at least he
would think but then i think in reality
there's so much more things you can
explore but i i do believe that to a
degree however the amount of people that
are watching youtube videos nowadays is
proportionally higher to the same number
of people that are trying to do
technology has made it easier to start i
think i think the tools at people's
disposal is is uh way more advanced and
way easier to use to get people to make
really cool stuff um that being said
like
i i feel
it's not quite like making a
channel with tv back in the day um
because the metrics of success if you're
starting up your own thing you don't
need nearly as many people
continue uh however i still think uh
something that jake said is i still
think hollywood treats youtube as this
grubby little corner that is like what
are you doing over there you
rambunctious rap again
because they've gotten older and then
we've barely gotten older and they're
still disguised but it's so funny
because i see i see it's just such it's
so dissonant between how they treat
certain things but youtube is always
just like this carved off like
dead zone of they can't do it and i
think it's because of the threat that it
is to traditional media like tv um
people do consume youtube as their tv
not even just netflix not even hulu they
do watch that but there are so many
people out there because youtube is
essentially free so long as you have an
internet connection every single video
on there or the vast majority of them
the vast vast majority of them are free
and accessible to anybody
and what that creates is a is is all of
this wonderful entertainment from
science videos to the corridor videos to
corridor crew videos to to marketplace
markiplier videos to gaming videos
there's so many different categories all
at the the accessible and open and yes
it is making us money it is it is making
us money but more importantly it's
making us as creators independent of the
people that hold the golden keys to the
golden gates of hollywood or whatever is
it's almost to the point and pretty much
is to the point where we can go we don't
actually need you anymore
we might have been asking to be a part
of that that world but you guys can make
movies all on your own you can make tv
shows all on your own if you have like
the funding for it you can take an idea
that you have and just make it i've done
it myself with like originals i mean
they gave funding but i know that i
could just take money i have and go make
whatever i want because i have the
skills for it you guys have more skills
than i do in terms of like the
filmmaking aspects and visual effects
aspects but even i with less skills can
still do that and so many people can are
starting to realize this is the reality
this is the truth of it we do are have
the golden keys too well yeah
it's that direct connection to the
audience because at the end of the day
like every show you know being made in
hollywood every movie
they only exist if the audience is there
and there's just you know it makes sense
because back in the day technology isn't
where it is now you know you have a lot
of middlemen to get
the content the entertainment to the
audience and
you know that barrier has been really
broken down now where you you know we
can be very direct with our audience
like our audience is there they we talk
to them every week you know we hire from
them we hire from them
yeah
and
you know it's like there's like a graph
i like i've constructed in my head where
like over time it's the it's like the
ease of which you can connect with your
audience
combined with the ease of which you can
make something right like
lights these days are so much easier to
handle than lights from 20 years ago
it's like weird bits of technology like
that but it's like
things you need like lights microphones
a lot easier camera's obviously way
better
gimbals like it's it's all getting so
much more accessible and we're not quite
there yet where you can just go and bang
out a movie just by yourself with
nothing like you got to put some effort
into it you got to get some resources
but like hashtag prompt masters prom
messers yeah once you have ai resolution
when all you gotta do is your one set
yeah prompts and then generate a movie
yeah like you know right now it still
takes some resources to go and make
something but like it's becoming so much
easier and then that connection with the
audience is becoming so much more direct
and like
i feel like we're not quite there now
but i feel like in about five to ten
years we'll finally meet that point
where like they truly are intersecting
and then like the big constructions
around like tv shows and movies are
gonna start to get real wobbly because
everybody's gonna be making tv shows
movies there's not everybody's not
making tv shows movies now because it's
still really hard to do that
but that's getting easier every year and
the access the audience to support that
monetarily and with attention is getting
better every year too so
who knows where it's going did you guys
ever have actual like cable television
once you left home
no
yeah me neither uh like when i was in
college i had friends who had like you
know you pay the exorbitant amount of
money per month for like cable tv or
whatever and i was just like i have
netflix it's got everything and no one
ever no actually it wasn't even netflix
that i cared about i was all about
youtube i spent even today or like in
general life today i spend so much more
time on youtube than any other platform
combined hbo disney uh hulu netflix um
i'm always defaulting to
to youtube because i know for a fact
there's going to be something there that
specifically interests me
and then i'll watch that one video and
now there's a million other videos in
the queue
uh but like
i i like people cord cutting was always
like a big talking point over the last
decade you know oh so many people are
getting rid of cable and i was like i
never had it
yeah does that count i don't know i
had it for like like i had it for like a
year about 10 years ago that was the
last time i had it but when hulu came
out
i had that for a while and then i got
off hulu but then hulu and then i was on
sling
and i flipped over to the prescription
services
because i got sling because they had
live sports and then hulu got live
sports and so i just have hulu for the
for the games that i watch on there
but then other than that i like the same
thing as you i pretty much when i'm
watching something it's a youtube
channel that i watch
yeah you know i uh actually just got
youtube tv for the first time ever and
it feels like regular old you know
channel scrolling tv but i only got it
because i wanted to watch the nba finals
yeah
and i have a two week trial for it and
as soon as the nba finals are over i'm
canceling it
yeah they've been hooking people on that
with the olympics and the baseball and
the nba finals yeah olympics is why i
did it uh not to not to besmirch our
youtube overlords we love you and
everything is wonderful and we love it
all it's great it's so good but i love
that 45 cents being taken out of every
dollar thank you
we love it
but what it what it uh what it shows is
is like
most of the stuff that is being made on
tv i would say probably 80 of it is not
worth people's time yeah that's the side
effect it's not even that it's good or
that it's bad it is simply not worth
people's time i know people bemoan like
the the two mid roles or the two ads now
on youtube and i'm i wouldn't like it to
not go higher than that personally um
but when it comes down to watching tv i
actually watched tv recently over at a
friend's house just because they had
nothing else no like and and
watch tv
shows with me
i had a terrible time just watching it
even if the content was moderately
interesting because there was just ads
every how many days seven minutes for
four minutes
the race
you'd have an hour slot for a 40-minute
show and like that means 20 minutes of
ads and each ad is 30 seconds long it's
so depressing it's what it is it's like
you just you understand the like the
veil is pulled away that actually
oh god i am just being sold [ __ ] that's
the only reason they cobbled together
this this show instead of like right now
streaming with no ads it's so much nicer
just to be able to pick something like
i'm watching alone me and my girlfriend
are watching alone love that show just
survival out in the witness have you
guys watched i watched the first episode
yeah it's very engaging very captivating
very simple concept they're filming
themselves which i think is super cool
um but no ads and it's like god i am
just here for the content itself and uh
youtube obviously is ad supported um but
there's a skip button
and there's youtube premium and this
youtube premium which i have and i
honestly love it's my favorite
subscription they they they try they
trash the initial launch with like
youtube red and they ruined all that but
i unironically think everybody should
get youtube premium because it supports
you know your creators more than ads do
and you don't get ads yeah you don't get
ads and you know that your value is like
over a hundred times more than any other
viewer not on youtube
so it's like if you want to support your
favorite creators getting youtube
premium well you get rid of ads that's
cool but like you are also directly
influencing
uh yeah you know but if you were to
focus you should go to
of youtube to not promote youtube
premium more than they do
yeah i don't i don't know if they quite
know
that the ratios in terms of what goes to
the creators who are who have people
watching who are on youtube premium but
it's the same reason why we started the
site it's just because the
you you have less people you can make
better content it's direct there's no
ads everything is just better for
everybody and i don't think youtube does
nearly a good enough job actually
explaining that to avid consumers they
promote youtube tv all the time but
well maybe it's because they still make
more money at the end of the day from
just all of the adsense that they come
rolling in they don't want it could be
that yeah droves google itself is an ad
company exactly foremost so they're just
like youtube
don't get rid of the ads
yeah don't push it too hard it couldn't
be but they also don't want people just
using adblock to get around ads either
yeah so that's why
they made that option i think there's
one thing that youtube's done that as i
reflect on it it was a really good move
and it's a really generous move honestly
and that is the effectively total
acceptance
of people doing their own ad reads and
brand integrations in their content
because youtube could have been like you
are cutting a slice from our pie
and it's a slice like how dare you
but like they really said you know you
know what we're just gonna be hands off
we're still gonna do our thing yeah but
you can do that if you want to you can
broker deals go for it i think that not
many people recognize just how
accommodating youtube has been with some
of the less popular things that they've
done say let's uh the the biggest one
being the uh the system to what's it
called to look at audio and detect it
what's
content id content id uh was a
compromise that they made because they
were sued i forget by who viacom viacom
they had to buy a comment a billion
dollars a billion dollar lawsuit was
brought forward and so the the other
option was shutting down youtube that
was the other option so they went with
an option that allowed creators to still
make content and not have their channels
deleted if they had copyrighted content
which was the other option and it's it's
funny because people on twitch are
running into this situation or ran into
it recently of like a half a year ago um
where they were just like you know had
copyright content and then they would
just get like a three-day ban or their
whole thing would get taken down
immediately because that was the risk of
being sued that twitch was like you are
not worth this risk but youtube
technically and by all accounts went to
bat for their creators and they still
believed in the environment of creators
being able to monetize their own stuff
just having to go through the legal
woodwork of everything of those before
and then all these twitch creators were
like let's band together we're just
going to play non-stop copyright stuff
and i'm just saying to myself is like
you don't understand
who you're fighting against
like it's not
amazon that you're trying to prove how
tough and united you are amazon could
pull the plug on twitch in a second
if they deem it's not worthy because all
these lawsuits coming in could cost them
more money and i don't think they've
made their money back on twitch yet
after the billion dollar purchase and
it's like
what what i always like i youtube's made
some shitty decisions of course and i
like stupid stuff all over the place but
they're all only human right they're all
only human and it's largely from google
anyway
but i really do believe that youtube is
the single best place for someone to
create content and find a niche and
build something for themselves that is
entirely self-funded of all the
platforms out there maybe tick-tock will
uh surpass it one day maybe these other
companies will but i think that the
metric is so far in youtube's favor
twitch is close uh but not if they keep
trying to
i gotta agree 100 like think about like
facebook and instagram it's like oh man
like do not be in that environment 100
like that's that's a bad basket to have
all of your eggs in and then tick tock
it's like
i mean that's such a wild west right now
i uh it is totally a wild west i assume
you know hank green correct yes yeah uh
he had an incredible breakdown of the
sort of like profit discrepancies
between youtube instagram and tick tock
and the way instagram and tick tock do
their sort of uh ad share with their
creators is very different than how
youtube does it you know uh
youtube has a split you said it earlier
jake uh they take 45 percent of every
dollar that comes in through the adsense
and
uh that's just blanket it doesn't matter
how much is made that's just how it
always is but on tick tock for instance
there's an actual creator fund and
everyone gets a proportion of that based
on how many views they get and i am not
going to be able to do any sort of
remotely comparable job to how hank
described it but essentially it comes
down to
the way tick tock does stuff is
disincentivizing people from
like trying to grow a business on that
platform and it's promoting people
burning themselves out
because tick tock has pretty much
straight up acknowledge they're like
yeah we don't care someone will replace
you if you stop
it's fine
yeah and instagram is kind of somewhere
in between it's a little like that and
then there's a couple
but like tick tocks revenue is in like
the dozens of billions of dollars and
they're only giving like 300 million
dollars or something like that maybe
it's a billion uh worldwide uh i think
it was like 300 million to american uh
creators
and compare that to the 10 or 15 billion
that went to american creators on
youtube or maybe it's global again i'm
getting some of these details mixed up
but the point remains is that youtube is
actually being a little bit more
generous with the overall share than
either tick tock or
instagram yeah yeah there's a couple
gripes i have with the other platforms
which is why we haven't quite dabbled in
them as hard as youtube um now honestly
you know twitch we're not really a
gaming centric
company it's and so you know even though
life has expanded a bit yeah or live
streaming that just hasn't made as much
sense for us so that's why on twitch it
hasn't really been anything else
but on on on facebook
it's it's been the constant excuse of
like oh well it took them how many years
to come up with like even a a legible
content id system it took him like a
decade
like literally it took him a decade to
come up with a legible content id system
um and so you know there was just
so many bad burns
from
that experience with them um and then on
the tick tock side
you know who knows i don't think i know
quite enough about the platform but i do
know that they've done some pretty
nefarious things with like how they
promote
different content
what they promote on that platform um
you know and and so it's just been
something that to me personally like i
just
you know it's just
who knows what they could do next you
know if they haven't like shown a
pattern of consistency and then like you
said ren i think they are promoting this
culture of just like
go
burn out and we'll replace you with
somebody else
it's it's pretty much why i don't really
care too much about tick tock despite it
being
overwhelmingly my largest social media
presence yeah i think it's a little bit
ahead of head and shoulders above the
others it's like literally a degree uh
like of magnitude but also what does
that even mean tangibly as a result my
my tick tocks like they can get up to
eight million views
views
i don't know what the view is uh but
there's no tangible benefit to me
because
tick tock disinfect disincentivize
anything
that gets people off the platform and
they never they don't send out
notifications really it's not really
that's not how it works all through the
feed you scroll through the feed and
that's it it chooses the ultimate
algorithmic uh decision and anything
that gets people off the platform if if
your video is like go check out this
it'll tank everything about that video
because it's like that's not good for us
so really like all of those amazing
numbers um i've yet to see anything
actually translate to something
benefiting me or anyone or i would be
surprised if businesses can really truly
thrive outside of let's say specific
mentions and ad reads and stuff like
that um but trying to build your
business like that is so inconsistent
because you do it once maybe and you'll
get like some traction from it and you
can't do it again because now tick tock
looks down upon your channel you know
i do fear the day where youtube's like
we switched something
in our system
so all the people that we're seeing vfx
rs reactor for saturday
aren't seeing it anymore in like the
algorithmic feed like in your
subscription feed you're still pretty in
control of that right
but
most people on youtube use the
algorithmic feed and it's like if for
some reason youtube is just like you
know yeah it's different
like we'll lose half our views in half
our revenue just like that but youtube's
been very cautious about that and we've
never had that experience with them
up to this point you like the ad
pocalypse keep waiting for it to happen
yeah dude i was like i'm okay this this
is a really cool wave we're riding here
vfx artists react it's really successful
right now a year and it's like man it's
still going uh i mean i don't know
it could end at any moment now
years later it's still going just as
strong as it's been too afraid and we
still don't trust it i don't think it's
as a
knife's edge as you think it is um
because
the way i consume youtube is less
algorithmic sometimes it is but most of
the time i have my key landmark channels
that i go to and i i go specifically i
don't even go to my sub feed i go to
that channel specifically interesting
when you build up a habit like every
saturday you have a vfx artist or
something similar to that i know that i
know that after three years that habit
is strong and that habit is extremely
strong with people that have been
following that for years i think the
reason that the the views are always
good is because the videos are good you
numb skulls people want to watch it
there is an entire segment of youtube
that is dedicated to those videos and
they're not going to go away just
because the algorithm changes it's going
to change if you change what the video
is true no the videos are actually good
i don't know if you realize mark how
much post-traumatic stress we have from
all the different types of videos we've
created over the years because we've
created some videos that have just torn
out our heart and soul when it comes to
like we put so much into this video and
oh man the concept just works and
and you put it out there and
put crickets but did that video mean
something strongly to the people that
did see it i always well so that's yeah
i i have a video oh no
well so just to finish that point but
then to some other videos like for
example the the premium example of this
so far in our history is world's longest
lightsaber
[Laughter]
we've been creating these short films
for years you know
production talent
like expenses big financial risks for us
like all these other things going into
it
nico comes up one day and goes
hey i wanna shoot this video with my
cell phone and we're gonna do some uh
very basic visual effects using after
effects composition and uh we're gonna
call it the world's longest lightsaber
it's gonna be great i go nico that video
is terrible it's not going to succeed no
one's going to like it
i don't think we should shoot it
he pushed forward on the idea they shot
it that video has like it's our most
viral video on youtube ever to this
point and it had maybe
you know it has 130 million views no
yeah it's closer i think that's 185
yeah
jesus it's like yeah last night i
checked it
out a while ago
let me just check real quick so we have
i mean yeah there's no it's 180 million
views there's not really a correlation
between how much effort a video takes
and how successful it is oh absolutely
right and that was a hard lesson first
quality are not the same thing well
somebody else has a video with the exact
same title and the same thumbnail uh i
saw that on our subreddit recently yeah
it's it's it is one of those things one
of my most actually my most popular
video is called meow it has 300 and
something million views um i put
eight hours of work into it i shouted
out it actually oddly enough had more
work than usually my videos but i was
just like
i was supposed to do a 10 million
subscriber milestone video i was like i
don't feel like doing it i'm just gonna
make this video instant success better
than any other video has ever done
better than five nights at freddy's
which was like really what put me on the
map i think it was a one out of ten
and it's just like oh this is before
even one out of ten came up but it'll be
one uh it's it's one it's like in the
top 10 of my videos still to this day of
total number of views i see you saw a
pattern you did meow wolf and moo i did
made no money on any of them because
they all got claimed immediately because
it's footage from just like random
animal videos have uploaded so i don't
know but it's just one of those things
where it's like i'll put all i put all
the effort in the world into my show
space um and i know i knew and i
understood that it would never get as
much success it didn't mean that that
video wasn't important to make
for me as a creative and i think for you
guys with all the incredible work that
you put into it just because a video
doesn't hit viral because of
uh the algorithm does not mean that it
did not have a significant impact on
someone inspiring them to move forward
and make stuff for themselves and i
think like that that value cannot be
understated yeah i mean a couple months
ago we did a video uh it was an iron
chef sort of parody not perry i don't
know if that's the right word the vfx
iron chef idea and we put a lot of
effort into the concept before we even
shot and then the day of shooting it was
a whole production thing and it bled
into the next day for like getting
pickups and all this stuff it was like a
big deal and we were all like
on board with that we're like yeah this
is this is a new format this is the
start of something big yeah and then it
went up and it was like our least
performing video of the previous 10.
yeah and it was like
that's interesting it's the thing but
then like uh then like the next week we
went to nab and so we got to like meet a
whole lot of people and talk with a
whole lot of people and so many of them
like that was such a good video we loved
it it was like one of the best videos
you guys have done in such a long time
and i'm like great
too bad no one else watched it on
youtube
yeah but it's also important to remember
like
100 people is a lot of people yeah a
thousand people is a lot of people yeah
a million people watching videos a ton
of people like
if so when a video gets 400 000 views
instead of
a million views that's four hundred
thousand people still like that's a lot
of people
that's ten people that's like 12
football stadiums of people who watched
your video so you can't get too upset
and compared to like tv numbers like
it's doing incredibly yeah and to be
fair none of us actually got upset over
that it was just one of those things was
like oh interesting data point
yeah now
now but when we were young and
younger and full more full of just like
hopes and dreams you know it was like
that stuff we had that expectation of
like and i think everybody goes through
this especially when they start but it's
this expectation of i put all this work
into this and it's got to do well the
the the the
content gods owe it to me to for this
video to perform well and then you and
then you realize that that's not how it
works and you know you you get but i
think you get better because of that
mark i gotta say so your meow woof and
moo thumbnails yes are very good
thumbnails thank you i'm looking at your
channel you have a very strong thumbnail
game thank you you make your own
thumbnails i make all my i've made every
thumbnail except for like one or two
when i had no access to a computer but
i've made the vast majority of the
thumbnails um
on my channel
and there's over 5000 videos so this is
this is like a gallery here just
scrolling through it yeah yeah this is
just i would compare it to uh when you
add people on you know it's just a thing
you do every day some of my best
thumbnails actually will never be seen
again because they were on the channel i
deleted with with ethan that we did i'm
just like really putting the work in and
that's a that's a great example of
putting work into something like so much
work into something for something that
is not tangible uh to people it was for
a feeling it was tangibly successful
don't get me wrong there was a lot of
people when we deleted it i think we was
like 1.7 million people watching
concurrently the live stream of us
deleting it it's crazy
but the feeling the feeling the feeling
there was everything the feeling was
i want to reiterate like people went all
all over when ninja like uh streamed
with uh uh drake and he got six hundred
thousand views and everyone's like oh
this is incredible
i was like i did 1.7 million
whatever shut up
but it's just one of those things
because i don't go out and break
this out two years ago so it's whatever
a side note to all this pieces is like
people always get so big on the numbers
people give all these can i curse yes
people give so many [ __ ] about the
numbers the numbers aren't important the
numbers were a side effect the idea
was to give people a feeling of
impermanence of feeling the loss the
nostalgia for something and taking it
away from them and committing to
something for a year that those feelings
cannot translate to numbers but that's
what enters the realm of art exactly the
performance art that was performance art
that really was yeah hell yeah it was it
left a mark on people people got tattoos
up and more tattoos of anything people
cherish the merch that they got more
just because it meant something and what
you guys do and i really hope you don't
think i'm just blowing smoke up your ass
like what you guys do means something
the content you make is important
some of it more than others of course
you know you have your throwaway videos
you have your meow equivalent but even
as long as lifesaver that's cool it's
very fun uh to see that kind of stuff it
means something it's important not all
content on youtube means something not
all of it has to mean something but the
stuff that you guys do does mean
something to so many people me included
oh oh yeah we've we've gone we've gotten
uh we've debated about that quite a bit
in the past like i remember there was an
old podcast we did and uh i was kind of
ragging on um
uh
on mr beast because i was you know kind
of i was kind of bitter about the fact
that his videos you know they didn't
mean as much as the artistic videos and
stuff but
i realized later you know
and you guys were kind of telling me
this in the cast but you were saying
look it that doesn't have to be that way
you know it's okay if people just want
to go on there and watch a cool video
for a couple minutes
and be entertained
they both have their place
and i was all grumpy about it and saying
no no it doesn't it's got to be it's got
to deliver something but
yeah it's an interesting point and i
think both both are important and and
one
you know
sometimes one does better than than the
other the majority of time the one
that's more entertaining to a broader
audience meaning less
does better but also that gives you the
opportunity to cast a wider net and to
bring those people into something else
that they might not expect
and i think that's that's important
about it too
have i told you the story about my
grandma and how like when she challenged
me for what i was going to go do for a
living i don't think so okay i'm not
sure i've even heard this story so i
actually just told this uh on the camera
for crew cuts but well
i'm gonna i'm gonna spice the story we
have a full tail here so yesterday we uh
we were visited by a make-a-wish uh
super cool person what's i don't know
what like what's that when you're saying
grantee but she's 19. so she's not like
a little kid um
like a make-a-wish lady
[Laughter]
and it was the first time we've ever had
that experience in the studio and it was
incredibly flattering it was incredibly
fulfilling
like i know people have want to visit
court or like we get emails saying i
want to come check out corridor and
usually we're like no sorry because we
have we have to work
um
but still like you know i think this
elevates it because somebody's really
going out of their way they're taking
their whole family they're making an
event and they wanted to come here and
like be here and see what we were doing
here and that was just such a
it was such a feeling like we actually
really truly achieved something you know
it really kind of like put that landmark
down
so back when i was
17 years old you know finishing up high
school gonna go off to college i already
knew i wanted to make videos i've been
making videos with sam for like four
years already that's when your hair was
like down to your shoulder yes the hair
was the longest it's ever been in my
life so it's come close a few times in
the past few years here
um
and you know like my whole family's been
very supportive like my grandmother her
name's maymay so my maymay
super support the most like supportive
woman i've ever met
uh and so like i'm sitting at the table
i'm like i'm about to head out and she
goes hey so here after school she's like
why aren't you becoming a doctor why
aren't you becoming a scientist why
aren't you doing something that'll help
people and i was like whoa i was not
expecting that because it's a sudden 180
and like i realized that she was really
kind of just testing me and like make me
pause and think about like how is
filmmaking going to be something that
can help people how can i like make
stuff or when i'm making things
pause and think about i decided not to
become a doctor i decided not to become
a scientist like i decided to go into
[Music]
films and put my time and effort into
films so with whatever i'm making what
am i doing that's going to at least help
somebody just a little bit you know
whether it's just purely entertainment
but ideally a little bit more thinking
about an idea reflecting on human
emotion like getting a little deeper or
just teaching people like
so that really stuck with me and then
when we had to make a wish kid
come and visit yesterday it felt like a
realization of that and unfortunately my
mommy passed away like two years ago but
as a guy yeah made me i did it i did it
look
it's worth it
i mean
i probably could help people out being a
doctor too but
you know kind of videos
so yeah
that's really sweet man
yeah but anyways i'll just go cry now so
see you later yeah yeah
no it's a debate we've had for years
yeah
that was it was very special i don't
know i'm still it was it was like a kind
of a surreal day yesterday it was like
yeah i knew that it was happening going
into the day i was like oh that's cool
but then when it actually started
happening i like in the moment i was
like
whoa this is a big deal like internally
not like it was a big deal quote-unquote
but like i realized it meant a lot to me
as it was happening i was like wow so
yeah i don't know
it's my only uh make-a-wish
experience so
yeah
what was your make-a-wish experience
like uh i mean i've had a few um i've
really been honored every time um
the first make-a-wish you know
i think was back in 2015 and that was a
really surreal experience i was out in a
small town on oregon um and then
i had a few afterwards and it was it was
very much like oh [ __ ] it's really cool
some some kid wanted me to uh be there
make a wish or their wish um and then
came the first kid who i met and was
hanging out with them and we were having
a good time and then i went home and
then
a couple weeks later i get a call that
they passed away damn and that that hit
like a truck because it made it at the
first part you you go out and you're
like hell yeah someone kid wants to see
me i'll try to have fun with them and
then it connects it like the reality of
it the sheer weight of the
responsibility of that of of knowing
that
you
were the person that a kid wanted to see
yeah before they died and it's crazy
that
that
man that just changed me
knowing that there there have been
people
who have followed my channel uh since
the beginning that have both had
children since i started youtube and
there have been people i've i i got
emails back in the past of parents
who told me that their child loved
watching my videos before they passed
wow it's
is heavy the reality of these numbers
the 400 000 the million the mr beast
level of numbers the reality of the
people behind there there's a term
called i believe a saunder
it's a it's a term that is is the
feeling of understanding that everyone
around you is living their own life and
experience and has all these dreams and
aspirations and failings and and sorrows
and insecurities
everyone has their own story around you
and
even
in all of these hundreds of thousands of
millions of numbers or whatever if you
can
land and make one person like really
really change their life for the better
or think for the better or
push them to do something
you
whether you guys like it or not whether
you guys think of it or not you have
done
again this is a bad comparison to make
because i never to be like one person
has done more good than another but you
have done so much
more good than you would ever know that
doctor that you could have been would
have saved untold number of lives like
echoed beyond what you guys have done in
terms of providing entertainment and
inspiration and pushing people to reach
for their dreams is value that can never
be measured and you cannot measure but
you must always remember an honor that
you have done that whether you like it
or not just by surely being consistent
and reaching for the stars with your
contented videos and uh i i told you
this you did not believe me but it's
true i would not be here i would not be
making youtube videos if you guys didn't
post that is literally true me neither
yeah exactly it is literally true i
would not be here i would not be able to
help people raise money for charity i
would not be able to do what i do if you
guys had not committed every day to like
really buckling down and working as hard
as you got and and look at you guys now
still still doing it i love that still
doing it man love that yeah and there's
something to be said for um
the consistency across the platform i
think across you know cr like yourself
all these other people out there
like just the ability of
to be able to get out there and do it
and do it consistently and to create an
audience around it
has its own effect unto itself that that
i think has that positivity even if your
videos aren't about hey guys welcome to
my channel today i'm going to teach you
how to be a better human you know
because honestly not not everybody wants
to see that anyways you know
if someone's making a video like that i
click away
exactly yeah but the the fact that you
you can as an exam be as an example to
people to say hey well this is what i
wanted to do
and i did it and so you
can find the thing that you want to do
and you can do it too
just that simple concept seeing that
manifested when you don't have it
yourself
is super important 100 also you know
i think
i think a good theme a good takeaway
from this whole podcast here is
you know we're all reliant on
someone else to have helped get us where
we are you know
sam and i only got into making videos
because
of you know a teacher at our school that
helped us out
and a website fx home alan tv back in
the day where's a bunch of users that
helped us out
i mean heck just the people making
actual movies and ilm and george lucas
and steven spielberg like you know if
those people if all that didn't exist
then we wouldn't even be here ourselves
not to mention like your parents and all
that and you go back further from that
to like the people that led to that so
it's i think it's always important to
really maintain that
i guess humility
and that gratefulness where you are but
that also kind of leads to everyday
being exciting and something that like
you can bring energy to when you are
approaching it like that was like this
is a gift that i have this it's a gift
that i can do this
and then you know you take all that and
let it fuel you to keep going and keep
making things and just stay consistent
with it
so but also never take yourself too
seriously because
yeah this one's good
experience when people turn up
billionaires
yeah no definitely the serious thing is
is is really good take away because it
happens and and when you do that people
they're not interested you know because
then you become disingenuous
and bring it back
yep
yeah
wow
all right good job i don't even know
where to take it from here i think
that's a good i think it's a good
stopping point it's a good thing about
on our drive's home
mark do you have a channel that you want
anybody to know about or anything else
like that no no but i want people to
know about the great quality merch
available on corridordigital.com
i think mark is subtly implying that we
do a really bad job of pushing our store
in our website
guys i just wanted to say how easy it
was to browse the amazing selection that
was on that website checking out was so
simple
did you know they offer free returns
but you know i've never had to use it
because the quality is so good every
time
wow always getting what i need
what's
[Laughter]
well there you have it everybody uh
thanks for tuning in uh mark i'm very
excited for what we can do um this month
and hopefully i can't wait to see brandy
or daniel teamed up with mark yeah i i
really
that one we gotta push for that one so
anyways
thanks for listening everybody and uh
yeah
all right see you later
[Music]